these are diplomats force or forces in
need of a seven-month but the park
amenities these are people need rescue
from be the point here is
the Empire is extremely important as it
was it's really important to general to
go as a way
cross way back
real power again
hishis idea was that this today we're
going to remake press with revolution
less horrifying and cleaning after
country in rid of Amy Ellis they were
going to expand about this and and so
they she does like she was applied
rigorously zealously in the Empire it
has some weird cosmic
your favorite
quotas and he's got two percent lawyers
or for that matter great increase Jewish
lawyers in places like Saigon genetic
answer so the quota thought is I meant
to be jiggle a little bit but
nevertheless with great zeal they
applying these matters to the Empire and
there was a very quite harsh manager
running teachers put into work camps
building the trans-sahara railroad that
was railroaded they began up from
Mediterranean into Central Africa
we're cast were they were not
concentrating a solicitor got something
against what they were very Graham place
and so this is any1 one of the ways
which this conference is baiting you
drown
you have two people know a very good
luck let me introduce our giant stars
and then our exam university of toronto
is
I would say the r
refresh Empire a century
in 33 articles and chapters in his CD
the number of books sometime astonishing
range examples of either China gas
the most important organization in the
tropics are all important
Roberto references in the tropics
trusted
and
everybody ate here
so he's going to talk about French
colonies professional oval window
Oh
and everybody touring car
thank you so much affection for those
kind words and take you to all the
organizers make that harriet island
and Jenny here so this morning and
yesterday there was a pheromone very
interesting interrogation about why
rescue was not necessarily considered
rescue org or was honest and we also
have some very interesting discussions
of why Jews are not be considered or
have not been considered as a righteous
category / say what I want to do right
now is interrogate the very concept
arrest and I could have provided a
broader summary of French colonial
practices around it seventh is Amanda
nicer get you some of that in my book
but I want to zoom in today on a very
specific case study which is a boat's
bow to mountain self-promote without
majority to bottom in late nineteen
forty nine before you want crammed full
of refugees they're not all these
refugees
in a minute but I want to begin the
presentation like this document which I
have gotten from the small problem from
a document at tools 70s doing the money
showing on the top does roughly 25 ships
that register going from either France
or Morocco to Matheny between the whole
of France and the end of this project of
which as I'll talk about is around May
1941 the discrete airships actually
continuing into 1942 the top category of
the ships leaving Europe for mountain
ich and the bottom category of our ships
heading back to the Metropole from
nominate usually handful of things like
rum bananas and other goods so um I did
first talk about what what this group
was and then they consider what what it
was was it expulsion was rescue I will
argue it because it makes a boat and
therefore I think cultures a question in
this instance what rescue means and then
also they'll consider what
this particular route which is also
equally complex questions it's probably
several factors inspired to do much but
first of all how tonight stumbleupon
this topic well it's a mystery bound up
in comprehensive exams when I'm doing my
comps at Berkeley I wanted to do
something on tropic a lady is a nice I
supervisor the wonderful the late
Susanna Pharaohs why don't you quite a
few piece of cookie and really very much
about tropic ality but I was completely
fixated by the voyage on board the
garden email with which the book
actually yet which is to say the voyage
to Methody and then from there quite
fortuitously on to New York in a school
research and so on its own and so I
asked myself like what conceivably was
it worked here was this spoke alone and
having gone to the French Caribbean full
of refugees providing many details about
conditions on board the boat which were
quite squalid he said well but she's
rather mysterious on exactly why the the
boat said say on the first place yv she
would that be oh and here's what he says
in pista pokey armed only with
new schools from New York you School for
Social Research I knew I must leave but
how and this is where is creating to
become particularly cryptic finally
obtained my ticket on board the core of
the man so I wonder bitter that this
easy where French jus to board a ship to
therapy in 1941 and I had a couple of
ideas in mind one was varying fri but I
was starting to discover great many
things I didn't know at the time that
cared for lunch working on a documentary
on him and so I imagine that area cry
was about for Elsa and another theory
that mo he says he knows an opportunity
to do who is renowned for having a saved
in particular a Jewish family using a
lot of members of their bases chauffeur
that maybe I don't be set CEO and
turns out neither was true in fact
either in this very much from could they
discuss in person because I wrote it and
you move back saying categorically very
gently I found out what the boat thanks
to my old contacts at the shipping
company and without any help whatsoever
ye would allow this bow to me I have no
idea at the time I thought it might be
transporting my best that material so 56
years after the fact issues motivation
for allowing this boat full of refugees
to leave remain completely fade unclear
to put equal semi so um why were these
25 boats bathing and much more why were
there so many quote-unquote celebrities
on board an essay gas alone all day
vessel you go Sam we fell down agreed
many intellectuals now here I obviously
suspected the charity Frey was involved
and so one of the first places I current
you was actually the butler library
right here columbia which most of you
probably know have the bavarian fried
papers and indeed i found some very
interesting things there ended variant
fries own memoirs surrender on demand
has a great many things to say here's
one excerpt that is
citing quote with the ships to Matheny
which really kept us busy us being
emergency rescue committee we could have
thought up anything better if you had
the power to arrange the rule ourselves
they were not sorry they not only
eliminated the trouble with the transit
visas they also remove the danger of the
trip through Spain for the event
directly from my saves money and from
there it was possible to go straight to
New York they were almost as good as the
bunch of your time that never realized
rescue ship which would have gone
directly from ma se to take refugees to
New York and so this made it clear to me
that very focused hacking into this sin
but it wasn't his doing that slide
please now this is a telegram that
variant fly sent to various benefactor
of the American rescue committee warning
them that the Martinique group was about
to be shut down by beach and you
describe the Matheny group very
eloquently as the best avenue of escape
that's actually
the best avenue of escape and so he uses
this as a way of gaining momentum
gaining funds but also gave him
awareness now this ness avenue of escape
very quickly uh i should mention it came
to an abrupt end in may june nineteen
forty one and i'll develop the the
reasons for this in a little bit but
between the fall of friends in may june
nineteen forty one there for some 23
cargoes passenger ships crammed with
refugees some having greater capacities
that others some of them carrying 50
refugees other carrying others 350
refugees didn t make their way message
they resembled advantages of the project
much of variant fri suspected one was
that you didn't need a visa to go to
Matheny Matheny was Vichy French soil
right so these people who've been lined
out desperate who have some wonderful
historical passages on this from vikki
character but he puts on ski from donna
ryan about the desperation and you saw
this in the documentary as well here
sahaja documentary
the desperation of these refugees some
Jewish some Spanish Civil War veterans
were recovered inside some anarchists
communists des particulars lining up at
these offices not just queuing in the US
consulate obviously that was one but
also queuing at mexican consoles for
symbian consulates you name it and not
finding anything and then being directed
and I probably won't have the time to go
to myriad ways in which they found their
way to these boats but being directed on
two cargoes or passenger liners to
Matheny where you didn't so much as
needed hedonistic that state it was much
easier to get in theory so he was the
best at the escape I'm sure it costs
money you're sure it helped to have
contacts but in a sense you didn't need
that much coveted almost impossible to
give either what would happen to Matheny
would be another matter orrible limbo as
I'm about to describe nevertheless out
of immediate harm's way of course saying
is it's a slight anachronism of the
final solution hasn't begun in earnest
at a time obviously right so that chewy
three factored is when we talk about
what if this was rescued or not then
the next slide okay this a remarkable
passage of the side is a remarkable
passage was penned by massive info I
don't have terribly much admiration for
myself it was home but that's neither
here nor there um she's interior
minister an old colonial hand who had
experience in Tunisia it's at least
obviously for men too but beyond that he
and Angie said so in his memoirs he
hadn't ruled on this project in fact he
was an instigator of this project in
some ways and in pinning him against
much more reactionary forces within me
she's colonial ministry and within the
community occasional read so this is the
telegram that sorry it's a letter that
the Minister of Interior sent to the
minister called ease on November 29th
1940 as I translated have the armored
informing you that i'm considering
practicing a policy of massive
immigration for foreigners who are
over-represented in the french
an economy taking their fill of consumer
goods without producing any of
themselves sometimes suffering from the
rigorous treatment that is by necessity
imposed on them such foreigners cannot
remain in this current limbo a sense of
social responsibility a concern that we
not falter on the rules of humanity give
us some curious obligation urgently to
arrange the departure of the greatest
number of them to warmer climates I have
the honor of asking you given the
urgency there is here for the
aforementioned reasons the distance
these people from a metropol when we
would be possible to direct a certain
numbers into the french caribbean drew
the state of these set foreigners would
be temporary nature and motivated purely
by the exceptional circumstances where
the manger sorry that would you possess
an ID so this is struck me as an amazing
past maybe his end good couch in the
language of over over-representation
sorts of characters look that the idea
that these refugees are reaches there
they're weighing on the national economy
but it's also couched in this imperious
humanitarian language it's very odd
though most schizophrenic in my eyes but
it's very much a reflection of its time
and I would argue that there's a kind of
best involved as a radical shift here
between the notion of humanitarian
obligation mean to welcome refugees into
France
I think was between 1933 and 1940s and
all of a sudden necessity being letting
him go or even pushing them up and here
we go back to what Robert Paxton was
saying about Jews being dumped on me she
quote unquote by the Nazis the kind of
bizarre punishment but also immigration
being a standard nazi line at this time
and be sure you are right so what you
often forget this when we look at 1948
verby 1941 all the more reason to think
that add the last and best escape on a
large scale to the new world um so this
this duality of language strikes me is
absolutely fundamental I could do it as
her presentation just on this passage
but i won't i'll move on very quickly to
say that the plan was implemented though
where I don't have as much as I would
like is in the proof approve of that
these people end up on these boats
because of business what I do have is
another letter just two months after
this initial one VG's the 10 minister
cabling the governor of money quote the
Ministry of Interior informs me of the
departure of 50 Jews mostly German for
the USA by anonymous I have granted them
rights of transit there's something else
going on here in addition to the tension
that I just described between these
colonial history which doesn't want
these people and the interior ministry
which paradoxically wants to get rid of
this is another thing that's going on
here which is and I'll talk about it in
greater length these role of the US and
I'll get back to that near the end so it
goes ahead it is as I said a kind of
combination of expulsion emigration
exodus rescue all of these words at
times could use to describe this project
depending on what angle you're taking
depending on wet vantage point it also
in many ways constitutes a kind of
continuity or legacy of some integration
schemes conceived in the 1930s to send
Jews elsewhere the you here for trying
to send a few gay but older schemes to
send to Madagascar topic language I've
heard an article sort of the fantasy of
the Madagascar plan but also it seems to
be coincides with the idea to colonies
as a bag as a peanut
and desirable so all of this wrapped up
in is paradoxical language of it once
getting rid of people and paradoxically
saving so this gets back to the sort of
buying field that you were talking about
this is morally it seems to me
straordinario complicated round now
responses were rapid and negative to
this plan for one thing is I just hinted
the governors of these comedies
themselves were extremely reticent to be
quote unquote flooded with refugees
regardless its ability of whether they
were Jewish communists and are kissed
and they didn't particularly make it
different some of the governor's
although interesting theories they're
interesting there is a slippage in
language at first there's just talk with
refugees increasingly as you saw between
the two telegrams I mentioned the letter
in telegram there's talk of there's more
talk of Jews and less talk of the
amorphous category of refugees
by early 1941 the governors of each
colony singled out in this plan web-nuke
Matheny and Viet had responded
unfavorably to phantom tools initiative
Matheny's governor I'll be place on
telegraph on january third 1941 full
routine the United States claims to
worry about the arrival of foreigners in
these parts especially about central
Europeans this was true and that's what
I get I'll get to that in a second but
there is in a sense there's several
things going on what is their genuine us
fear above these wolves in sheep's
clothing for lack of a better word how
you German spies masquerading as
refugees trying to get to the United
States but there's also these
anti-semitic governors none more so than
or in charge of these particular coins
raises Semites you name it a mortgage NP
she in some cases using the pretext of
an American concern as cause for
rejection so there's several ways of
readings done be this as it may um there
was unanimity between the three columns
french guiana is governor will damn show
had sent a virtually identical message
quote arrival of funny ladies bearing
german sounding names and use of pretext
for America's seeking any excuse to
dislodge the Vichy regime for the French
Caribbean will not get back to American
public movie in a second as for the
governor of Lihue post also on the coast
local victim of a new he proved equally
unreceptive after the first wave of
refugees arrived even though there are
persistent rumors that his wife was
Jewish incidentally he cablevision Marge
nineteenth nineteen forty one I deem it
appropriate hence court to refuse all
requests for Israelites settle here in
web loop there are serious and
conveniences in establishing a time of
jewish immigration capable of becoming a
beachhead as n a community which would
be facilitated by the proximity of the
USA their religious poll
they commended for is drawing up a
variable conspiracy here about Jews
using the French Caribbean as a kind of
beachhead now ultimately the plan as I
told you reach a truck and in May 1941
to be precise on May twenty-fifth
nineteen forty one when one of these
vessels actually two of them that
Winnipeg and the Audi cap or intercepted
and boarded by a Dutch warship operating
on behalf of the Americans in the
British in the Caribbean they boarded it
on a tip that there were Nazi spies on
more and that essentially do the project
they're after both still came to and
from not to be from France but the
passenger list were sort of Douglas
checked the couch commissioned the
Germans wanted to see at this point
alyssa passengers we're leaving my side
and then the Americans demanded to see
the list of passengers arriving Matheny
making it nearly impossible to exploit
the line in the same way to add until
May metric 41
so what are the reasons for the failure
well you can already guess what i said
of their several reasons at work there
was a very real American resistance to
immigration and I would add a kind of
American paranoia about matunuck in the
first place Matheny and wiki I would say
it's almost the kind of fears of Cuba
within the Americans fear that we have
had a 20th century in lake my eccentric
50 minutes let me explain headlines in
the New York Times of 1941 around this
time a 20-second read things like
Matheny aid in the accident the axis or
manic is prepared to resist expected us
attack to add to the confusion in
February 1942 a German u-boat sailor
with his leg shot off had mysteriously
showing up on a beach in Matheny
actually badly wounded at sea his
companion just shoved them off on come
to the beach and holds the medical
treatment and her last abruptly but
there was a widespread due west
perception us
that vitiates which of course were in
large numbers in Matthew or don't think
that there was also the hand of Nazi
Germany left for working and that there
were Nazi spies all over the place not
to me but loop which of course I found
very little evidence what I found in my
book the rubber passes kind of dimension
whispers actually is she doing of course
its own clothing of its own ideology so
you would have many Germans there
nevertheless it's fear it seems to me
it's very important because attorney
would be used by the governors of these
colonies to reject and ultimately
scuttle the plan but of course the
ultimate killing of the plan came from
what had been a US and British blockade
from the start in fact when you read the
testimonies of survivors of the refugees
on board the ships they all say that the
crew is extremely nervous boats were
being regularly sunk sometimes
mistakenly so in this era right this was
a very difficult thing to do in fact the
butter in them we now know as it was
heading to Gibraltar rupt about face
because it saw a British destroyer and
then it left in the dark so this was
another perilous passage and to some it
seems the very fact that he's both were
getting through was in itself a
suspicious thing it must mean that there
was something
Edward even you'll recall the letter
from booty disposed to me said at the
time I I suggest I thought something was
afoot that he was carrying clandestine
material there was another word
something that just seemed odd about
these passenger boats even making the
passage over after this of course French
beers that I've just talked about but
also the Vichy French peers but also
unlike older French here which goes back
to the post World War 1 era which was
that the penta Caribbean would be
offered to the US as a kind of tributes
to thank america for its involvement in
what we're one constant fear articulated
very interestingly by Matson again
whether beyond that the US would get
older the colonies in the US were more
racist than the French and would impose
Jim Crow on the French Caribbean so
player upon layer of fears some more
some better founded than others can
explain the ultimate failure of this
plan but let me zoom in for just a
couple of minutes on the US views the US
had a person on the ground reporting
very seriously on
their console not said not the age and
his papers at in Washington DC are very
rich actually on this so sorry the State
Department is asking that leads to
report back on vocals of these boats of
refugees and March 1941 in other words
just before the wave of biggest wage of
arrivals mouse and mash metias office
did not altogether discount the
possibility of wolves posing in sheep's
clothing cares when he reported to the
State Department quote a limited number
of vessels have arrived involved with
halls bringing refugees from a say in
Casablanca of which the majority of
French intermingled with Czechoslovakia
Belgians poles and Germans there are
constant rumors that while these German
refugees should themselves turned out to
be but a feat bonafide refugees there
are among them a number of Nazi agents
who are using month needs a jumping off
point to travel to various American
Republic's notably Brazil in the US and
that some of them are at present
residing a design although all attempts
to verify these rumors have been
unsuccessful the fact that they're super
system these may believe that there may
be some truth by July of the same year
however he was exasperated saying quote
Germans here we're now I'm used bicep
stories except when we have to devote
overtime to gathering actual proof that
they are dead wrong
so multiple screens were at work both
and departure and upon arrival I won't
dedicate my side to this but they're
incredibly fortuitous sad tragic
consequences to who was in what office
when in MA say sometimes it's a police
officer who tips off refugees about
where to go sometimes it's regular
citizens sometimes it's word about
oftentimes it's the American rescue so
there are different ways of finding out
how we get on to these mountain each
pose perhaps the saddest tale is that of
bright sides and filtered in Rudolph
Broughton shut former president of the
german social democratic party weird all
filled for doing the former minister of
finance and von maur who has probably
knows the story from me from the
variance friday papers for children you
can get on these boats and so they
quickly showed up and try to get tickets
in the neighborhood will give your
standing you really should have you know
more than just a bunch you should have
your own room wait for the next close
and then of course by the time they did
we've been taken away and at this point
this is of course d she doing the
Germans work for than handing it over to
ensure
Ernie's than their tales of complicity
remarkable tales including that of
Walter merit so again something that
comes up in varying fries papers and
there's an interesting legal disjuncture
between various rice papers and memoirs
on this but let me quote from let me
quote from the from the papers
themselves examining my paper says Mary
the chief took out a card so that I
could read it the French police chief
Walter married as I mean so filled with
false they see Hilda ecliptic Umizoomi
you pull the prefecture ten minutes
later a backpack papers and said smiling
sympathy photos the walter berry another
Walter may go so there's different ways
getting on board some involved Felicity
connivance breaking of the rules
following of rules I'm gonna have to
leave it at that but I want to reinforce
the idea that this is at once
experienced by some as an expulsion
experienced by others as as rent
I also should say when motley makes this
is on board the ships I have any three
minutes to do some social history but
the next slide please so this passage
which of course I've written so small
that I'm going to have to actually stand
over here to read it's from Vic Toews am
and because that was wonderful memoirs
but again his men horns and his papers
which are held at Yale don't say quite
exactly the same thing because I was a
famous belgian-born revolutionary who
married
woman who herself a business dog refer
of that enemies astonishing the leg and
jacquard here's with ito staff says his
own papers we arrived in mouth technique
in the last days of April 1941 us that
is to say 300 refugees from Europe a
little over 200 of them reduced to
fleeing the old continent only because
they belong to the people who gave the
world Christ Spinoza marks control the
change on many reactionaries amongst
them incidentally a little under a
hundred revolutionaries filled with the
memories of their grand struggles and
their defeats full of hope nonetheless
heroic defenders of Madrid fighters of
2n and the Asturias militants from
Barcelona the first soldiers the Second
World War and of the European revolution
German and Austrian socialists who leave
behind them working house in Vienna
attacked by Gophers hit Larry
concentration camps and the tombs and
comrades decapitated with axes or hanged
in sales of da hah survivors of the
purchase of Russia and refer is
everywhere doggedly faithful and
clairvoyant towards Russian Revolution
together we know all totalitarian
regimes in a sense all of the jails all
kinds of suffering all of their plans
for global domination so not only is
this kind of international of resistance
against fascism recording
it's also in a sense a hodgepodge of
Republicans from those bandages of the
war of Jews of Democrat Social Democrats
etcetera etcetera this passage actually
struck me is quite powerful and I didn't
do it justice French version is much
more powerful at the next line Thank You
of this picture from the u.s. Holocaust
Museum followed by the next one gives us
another sense of his mom that crew here
you have some of the personalities on
boards of fun than now on that fateful
voyage amongst them the Cuban
sino-african inter afraid of land and
i'll get back to him in a little bit he
had the volunteer on a Republican side
and very much stuff like he would be a
victim of Nazi of reprisals the
conditions on board were dreadful I
don't have much time to go into that so
I won't uh but I should quickly turn to
the reception that they got the putter
Bible in not to the next slide please
this remarkable document that I got
invested in the seven seas doing that
any false the
army archives in other words shows the
orders that Admiral Howe bail and that
was men about how to put unquote greet
these refugees there were different get
fuel different scenarios depending on
whether they were French or fraud you'll
see that if their situation was no Linda
Moulton out so he didn't need a visa
bitch attendees a mystic Betsy to be in
math unique the solution was worth food
water for Milkha don't get rid of them
interment in the meantime to delay the
legality of all of these measures is
something that all the records question
they basically called this gentleman
called the via the polish-born
avant-garde photographer said they threw
us into a concentration we left here to
be thrown into a concentration and so
the other thing that this document shows
without going into terribly much detail
is the imperative of getting people out
of it Matty would be a layover not a
definitive plans and the most of these
people do an echo in Brazil to Mexico
United States and elsewhere but the
point that I wanna make very briefly
here is that they are treated dreadfully
on location the ways in which their food
of course our experience very different
than looking at a whole bunch of papers
on us some express in terms of racial
hierarchies several refugees I want
those names just now but say things like
we are being guarded by Negroes quote
unquote there's some fascinating
responses to this several state of
distance that is da ho and any
conditions are written in these in this
camp it of course it is a refugee camp a
very badly caps refugee camp but it
works not a death camp in in a sense
could I have the next slide please
next last week these pictures I just got
two weeks ago from the German cool
collection no can't nope okay no
photographs were allowed his hands gem
include was a photographer she managed
camouflage her camera and to take his
remarkable photos of these refugees
lining up for water at the design there
were two camps and not to me when we
felt bad I thought it was the best ahead
conditions were awful people got
sunstroke it were very hungry and
thirsty tempers soured people
desperately try to get out to bribe some
of the gang but move beyond guards to
get out Jonah impudent you manage to go
complaining to the governor in person is
it oh not to worry we'll improve your
face of course nothing happened but i
thought i would show you just his
handful of shots of people on location
this one's my knowledge virtually
unknown this is we fit of lamb and his
wife
in the camp of Eliza next slide please
this one shows well this is actually the
wording of gentleman who that haven't
even really had a chance to check up on
some of these people but Jack then he
seated on the lower left his real name
was si yes Jewish the Belgian law
student I have no way of knowing he was
Jewish deed of sale met him MV from
Luxembourg no I give up her origins a
German engineer that he said of course
was half Jewish and thick dosa also a
painter so you have again this
remarkable combination intellectuals of
dissidents of refugees of political
exiles of Jews but communist all of them
together in this camp and the gray
matter in the particular camp was very
remarkable as well next slide please um
I want to close my eye for sure how I'm
doing our time but I want to comply ok
ok I want to close with the exhibit
that's currently running in Paris a bit
more about it
hello mrs. Lummis easily fellow don
pablo picasso moving some coffee which
actually goes over this episode of a
very different bandage boy which I
wasn't able to explore it all today
which is that an intellectual and
artistic history because of course what
happens from this is the remarkable
confluence in synergy between other one
has the realism and on the other hand
Negritude the famous encounter between
on the one hand Suzanne Suzanne this is
at and mocha compete and on the other
hand people like we've read about we've
got Sam all defense and ultra portal and
also in particular this energy came at
him and this is f is a very powerful but
close on another complicating idea
because this paper was a part and part
about breaking down some categories of
showing that rescue can also be
expulsion I want to suggest that in some
ways that encounter though is a little
bit whitewashed by exhibit it's a
wonderful exhibit showing some wonderful
paintings by lump by gesso and some
wonderful poetry by a mrs. a
and really remarkable documentary as
well but what it doesn't talk about is
some of the context I just brought out
the ways in which these people were
throwing out a furor over States Europe
and it also doesn't talk about the
context on location somebody that often
booked already picks up a copy so this
is wonderful this is an articulation of
Negritude mrs. this is very close to
surrealism but what he doesn't know
which I hope to argue one day in a book
about this is that in some ways but we
also managed to elude DC censorship by
saying things like we are essentially
Africa we are of an African identity we
are not we are different we are who we
are and this man is forgiven thee
censorship if you like that phrase or
perhaps please use exertion if you
prefer that there's a way in which this
particular synergy encounter is
incredibly politically charged so I'll
let your questions
private life
the second paper proper tap off
wrong
as Roberts at office the executive
director of the Washington Institute for
Near East policy is a farm policy
advisor and expert and writes those
matters also a scholar with degrees Duke
Harvard and Oxford in the author of nine
books monographs not call attention to
one of those
from the righteous lost stories from the
Holocaust long reach into Arab lands
which is about rescue in more
traditional terms particularly in
german-occupied Tunisia our rescuers
that work was awarded to Daniel girl
award
board for cars promotion and
prizes it's also setting the documentary
which was found about a year ago in pdx
so please talk about our aggressive
Africa
thank you good afternoon I just realized
here in America wouldn't eat a bit my
entire professional career the last 26
years focused on some obscure doesn't
written hot humid
first I really would the reason why I'm
here is because inside the auspices of
professor Paxton me of course will have
no reason to remember this but when I
was first starting out on the research
that I did almost ten years ago kept
this email exchange online
number old computer i sent him a note no
reason over what was a time a school
whether he thought it
whether he agreed with the idea that the
widen see dr. the policy document when
it refers to seven hundred thousand Jews
of France whether the Germans were on
track including the Jews of refresh
possessions and North Africans is there
any other way that they could come up
with the seven hundred thousand we
should some circles is in fact a very
controversial question
and he said I don't have any other right
but but I don't see how they come up
with a number including any other and so
that helped me early Roman tonight
so thank you very much and because one
of the coffee's organizers Harriet
Jackson for some has her own personal
connections this story her father was
insured in Marfa which is secure transit
point at the end of the Moroccan portion
of the trans-sahara trim and some beef
in corresponding about this quite some
time so thank you very much for
including digit 1 and n just one day
everyone was referring to earlier to
that looking for publishers I'm not
looking for any with publisher like
looking for French polish
who's been published in Arabic and
Hebrew tonight that circle Croatian
that's never happened because of there's
a certain sensitivity in France of it
between maybe some of your heard about
two jews and arabs and muslims etc the
signal strength publisher to her be
interested in that in translating my
work so if anybody has contacts that are
all ears one last word of
preparatory note i'm not a historical
holocrons I feel quite humbled to be in
this room with people who know a lot
more about the subject but I do I know
something about the Middle East I'm a
historian of modern era politics I know
a lot about Arabs and Muslims and our
politics and very little certainly not
professional about the Holocaust and
secondly I came to this too microcredit
hear about with interpolated rationale
quite open about an approaching which is
is there a more effective way to discuss
questions about Holocaust with our study
out of Arab and Muslim societies our
biblical cultures is there a way beyond
the traditional way of
the traditional story of European
fascists killa killa european jews which
is of course the overwhelming story well
cost but not terribly effective in
trying to extend holocaust education and
genocide queries and why they're erica
muslim societies is there a more
effective way to do tins and it occurred
to me one day to ask a question did any
howard save and perhaps through that for
that window it can be the answer is yes
assume the answer is yes and i worked
backwards from read some if indeed the
answer was yes would that be a winner
through which one could have a more or
less Conda less argumentative and at
least beginning a more cooperative
discussion about the Holocaust would be
societies so that's where I approached
with some pickles I wanted to say that
it from I'm going to talk about the
empire but I thought given me in
discussion we've had so far I should at
least make reference to perhaps the most
celebrated story
of an Arab gain the metropole assistant
and I would argue even rescuing a
certain number of Jews the Arab is not
the guy in the german-american question
is the gentleman to the right with
secret or bank agreed who's the most
influential Muslim in Europe most
influential Arab in Europe what people
think that the multi in Jerusalem haj
amin al-husseini most influential
inherit the earth that's not true the
most influential Harbinger by far was
this gentleman who is the founder Bill
director and a map of the brahmos Katy
Perry the Great Mosque Paris he's
enormously intellectually
person for seven decades he's Algerian
born about service and translator for
the Sultan of Morocco very odd career
but by this time he is an extremely
powerful influential person in Paris and
so story goes and not believe that there
is considerable evidence certainly
compelling others
the Grand Mosque Paris which probably
all seen make some of you have visited
the left bank helped quite a number of
Jews in a rather ingenious way these
offensively Jews from one set of the
preference eat the main number of
Muslims and powders were or Arabs rather
were of North African origin and they
most of them were there because it had
fought in world war one for the French
and state
the Jews in question were Jews also for
what Africa with whom they shared
language culture with many pirates
frequented mosque and there's compelling
evidence that the mosque provided
documentation that that let a
significant number of Jews passes
whistle there's a very famous story for
example of the Algerian Jewish singer
see what Al Ahly would just passed away
2005 who everyone in his obituary when
he passed away included the story that
they debrief protected them by giving
him false identities and wisdom and
because he was so famous bengali went
the extra step of arranging for a
cemetery flock debt muslim cemetery
outside Paris to have a tombstone in
brain with with simona de la Lee's
father's name on it
that haven't been able to confirm that
there is a two-zone to see what allows
but this is certain this is certainly
when the holock family was perfectly
happy to let people know was the story
and another ism I think there's a wild
speculation that up to 1,700 Jews were
saved this way i think that perform more
realistic number 500 that were given
just support by the boss which is not
insignificant there's a fantastic little
film by an algerian non-jewish burglar
filmmaker named air evac any old lemon
tea stalls nmda that is about this story
and in just last year a wonderful
children came out for little kids five
six years old called the mosque that's a
jew and its effect on people okay so
much for the Metropole at least one to
connect what are you doing it
ever go to the rest rest of friends let
me go back here
let me very quickly ask or pose the
balance of my time three questions now
what happened to the Jews in our country
what role did ours play in all of this
and specifically did any hour to save
any choose now first let me let me
borrow the topic considerably we're
going to focus on Lookout we're not
going to focus on French Syria Lebanon
there's a story be told there a story is
very brief the Allies read certain
Lebanon by springer koat one the store
data very brief the real story is here
in north africa algeria morocco tunisia
each of those under some they're
slightly different legal status from the
other algeria is this room knows that
you're part of France
morocco tunisia at different
protectorate status algeria the laws the
application of laws and something
different in each place i'm not going to
go into the nuances in this discussion
because i don't have time i'm just going
to give you the broad the broad story i
should also say again what i'm referring
in short game for when i say our
university campus I should be very
careful to use my terminology
a goodly portion of the people that are
returns it will not involve a pervert
and as an important acne distinction
here for short hands form i'm using arab
to report to refer to the local
population of these countries which we
can get into further details if you like
it in with discussion so first what
happened to Jews and other countries
hear from Jeff are referred to the with
one exception the short story is that
everything that happened in Europe
persecutions confiscation internment
slave labor deportation execution in
various places and to varying degrees
everything that happened to Newark
happens in these things and the one
exception to that list was extermination
extermination do not have in
romantic and here telegraphic one
sentence answer why is tied in space the
war was over in what was over Morocco
Algeria by November of 1942 or was over
Tunisia and by spring of nineteen
forty-three the Jews of these countries
were lucky lucky that the Allied
strategy began in North Africa into the
end no matter they were also lucky that
there was a Mediterranean that separated
them from the death camps in Europe and
there wasn't a single landmass had a
single dad passed the trains would have
go but to loot them my boat was totally
different undertaking
so I think time and space with the basic
why you did not have extra extermination
but you did have everything else here
for example southern mentioned earlier
passing invention the step choose the
steps that's usually I was applied in
some cases greater for all city in these
countries than in these territories that
it wasn't France the quota system was
more difficult in some places Algerian
jury and Jews lost their citizenship
quite rare among places that fell under
Nazi control does he think only germany
austria in algeria where else did the
jews lose their citizenship throughout
the war
here you see you see a map from major
staff report that looked at internment
camps that were set up in Morocco
Algeria and Tunisia that were eventually
114 places of internal that were
recognized by agreements with claims
conference in the german government 114
places in bed include libya recognized
and it was the last group of people with
whom agreements were made on their
behalf was
virtual regions that were there are
nuances here Moroccan Jews were not sent
to internment camps that's certainly not
pertaining Jewish I'm rocking there were
some Moroccan Jews sent to internment
camps for political reasons socialists
anti-nazi activists but not from being
Jewish camps in Morocco but principally
for Jews deported from Europe for
various reasons refugees or 44 souls who
actually joining the Foreign Legion
thinking that they were going to escape
the war in Europe got sent to do their
national service sites in Morocco and
then woke up one day and we're under
arrest and were sent to work camps these
places were pretty horrific those there
is a separation to the work camp an
internment camp and
Camp specific camps set up for the sole
reason punishment Jews it was one all
Jewish camp even though they were there
are lots of other people that were sent
there at Spanish Republicans etc that
was one of old Jewish camp in eastern
Morocco camp at berghain now it's called
Ivan many montage and these were pretty
horrific pretty places in Algeria was
different story people get said Algerian
% summer camps certain point
cookie sheet and Tunisia of course has
its own unique experience because the
Germans and the Italians giving all the
partial support with the Germans setting
up their own digital cameras and doing
round up some Jews don't get to that
Justin Walter Ralph the SS Colonel Randy
Randy the SS effort in Tunisia not you
know the thing this is a backwater of
the what the Germans were doing in
Europe Ralph deployment underscores that
this was a lot of that work for the
Germans Ralph had originally the task of
following wrong plan was the Ronald will
go through Egypt go to Palestine rouse
was to kill all the Jews along the way
that was his mission Ralph had quite a
lot of experience doing it because Ralph
had fought again well had developed a
mobile death cast of a means to Europe
very efficient at killing
and so it was his plan to do this in
North Africa and when when things didn't
work out for wrong routes backup mission
was to attend to the juice attorney and
so this was not a this was not an Africa
this was somebody serious that they
deployed to you as i said earlier to
choose where we send off for labor camps
five thousand jews and tunisia percent
off a german occupation this is his
photos i like to include it because it
underscores that they were sent home the
labor camp right in the middle of
downtown tunes this was not a secret
enterprise everybody knew what was going
on their interviews they interview some
of these people that talk about how
probably being jeered all the way by by
the Arabs who were made from were
applauded the dispatch of these Jews
through Tunisia tradition shoes have
there they are equivalent of
Kristallnacht if you will there
they're equivalent of the lamasa in
Paris which is under seven ninth 1942
which is the ruffle ruffle
the routing of juice in
into the yellow stuff what most people
don't think that the illest arm is
included in Africa factor was now into
ms itself but all problem all the rest
tunisia there's some discussion about
French officers preparing this from
Moroccan Jews as well that never
proceeded beyond the discussion point as
a regrettably apocryphal story it's a
long story is apocryphal about southern
morocco yes telling you the French
governor-general when so the story goes
in French governor-general goes to
supplement is we just print enough
200,000 starters from choosing morocco
and the Sultan says we need to print
them 20
20 Sultan pages for me and my family
it's a wonderful story but the more
important part about that story I'll get
you a little later is all the more i
believe the ova moroccan jubilee and
that's really the most important aspect
of the story is how they view the soul
some of them earlier I showed lining up
for dispatch to labor camps in the
middle of town many of these camps were
the middle of nowhere this is this is
Kendra which is in the long transit our
railway really the middle of absolutely
no mere nearly Moroccan Algerian border
I took my wife and kids there for
thanksgiving holiday
my kids without hang up so I said walk
to Algeria the time what is really
interesting about about this men's many
things that can on black but this was
this was a horrific place you have to
imagine the scene for a moment undies
many of them have these Jews started
their journey in Leipzig or in Budapest
or Berlin or somewhere made it to France
they're wearing their yucca three-piece
suits and their big heavy shoes and
whatever is there they made it to France
know where their legal refugees rounded
up one night and throw it on a boat set
to cross the Mediterranean and sent
without you know with barely any food or
any water sent in a cattle car to this
place they open up the door the cattle
car was still wearing their no big east
european wool suits and as 140 and
they're told it ok did it say they had
no place to live they dug holes in the
hill aground and they covered it with
tent coverings and that's where they and
that was their experience so
I don't mean to inject lemony because it
really was a horrific experience and a
cultural and psychological sense as well
as the physical sense and this is their
social German constructed buildings left
in these countries this is a camp in the
Zetas the last remaining German labor
camp this is a Tunisian port town is
there okay what role did our play the
basic story again one sentences they
played almost the majority of bystanders
some of them were some of them were my
standards in the sense that their war
was hella niggas they just had their too
much of their own life and their own
existing for families to worry about and
had no time or ability to worry about
anything else there were also those
bystanders who were passive cheers
or passive supporters but not but at
most you talked about earlier ruggeri I
could use from the windows and there's
lots of lots of examples yes i would say
that refers that category bystanders is
by is by far the vast majority what
happened vast majority local reaction
then you had your chairs there people
who are full-fledged collaborates with
what we shootin what the what the
Germans were true
people volunteered to be transmitters
people who served as custodians of
Jewish property lots of Jewish property
was taken especially in Algeria in some
places people volunteered to attend an
over at best profit along the way you
had people who service the cats in bloom
and trains people who who were full
fledged parties to what was going on
high levels I'm going to talk a moment
about the something about something mom
in Morocco but you had the Prime
Minister former self of Muhammad was on
one side of this is prime minister
totally on the other side Figgis deeds
with me and you had high level people
who were deeply engaged in the
enterprise so you have your collaborator
there's some of this voter chapter in my
book to the terrible story
family in Tunis who was turned in to the
Germans by their Arab friend and it was
that friends testim who lands them not
just jail but deportation and eventual
execution how the earth so you had all
of these types of club of collaborators
and then you have different levels of
depressors and I say different levels
because there are categories different
types of help and assistance am i doing
lots of interviews across many many
stories people referring to the our
Baker who put to an extra loaf of bread
behind the window so that this band to
get extra rations or the Arab who put
two bottles of milk
dad actually had kids and Jews working
the low end of the ration liner that
when Europeans Muslims and the Jews
rationing Africa lots of stories of
these sorts of acts of kindness access
to vegetarians many by people whose
names we will never know but they were
known they were remembered by the Jews
of the time and deeply gratified by the
assistance they receive from you then
you have political leaders such as here
sultan muhammad we go 44 or more
importantly Munsif bay the ruler of
tunisia we tend to know something about
muhammad because he's kept a because
there's a lot of you stonework and
cuz his memories kept alive by the
walkins and the magician tend to go a
lot less about months of pay because the
monarchy was throwing away in 56 months
ebay himself was that was accused of
collaboration by the allies it was
forced for his throat but in fact mother
pay my view can gets robbed the Oakland
history once if they did quite a bit to
pretend the Jewish community of Tunisia
he put in the most followers of a cabin
that Tunisia ever knew
there's many stories of individual Jews
whoa there that property and their lives
to who came in his course perhaps the
best explanation of world Sultan month
they perform was given to me by his
grandnephew a couple years ago who I
want to be was living at the time was on
his deathbed he was living in a
apartment building in Tunis on Palestine
right next door to the grand rabbi in
the same apartment floor and he
explained to me this is the the stripped
of other titles but this was in disguise
grand nephew nephew
that explains that you see this
apartment this apartment was paid for by
the Jewish usin my health care it was
paid for by the Jews see my kids
education was paid for by the Jewish
Junior that is what the Jewish community
remembers of what life family did for
them during this period I thought that
was a rather moving testimony they
didn't actually say Jewish lives I don't
have any evidence that something about
of the fifth of us at bein saved a
particular Jewish life when they did is
give any fight and moral support
publicly at key moments second take
steps to slow down the imposition of
vision wounds and impede the imposition
of the she-wolves famous story morocco
me she's seeking to take a census of
Jewish property the Sultan knew that
this was this was very bad news from
jury
and he's found many ways to slow it down
no ways to assure would not be
comprehensive and then at a certain
moment he arranged for the leaders of
the Jewish community just to be had a
secret meeting inside the palace they
were ushered thing came into the back of
a vegetable truck knowing some of these
people to see them at the back of a
vegetable truck itself as it does in the
market is an amazing we got an image to
have to meet with the Sultan and for him
to promise them that he personally will
ensure that all of the records of the
census will be burned and so that nobody
will ever have access to the records
incense and indeed that essentially is
what was done so that's that's the
politically
important to remember very important to
removal I also think I found stories of
rescue and I know this is bri will be
toward the close of what I wanted to say
that I think it's important to spend a
few minutes just some individual stories
see AMI Sekot note 11 former member of
tunis in was a Jewish was a German camp
on a piece of under a bridge on a
property right next to his country home
in this up on bail which is about 35
kilometers south of to miss which just
happened to be right in the middle of
the battle battle raging between the
Germans bridges Americans during the
heat of battle 60 Jews escape from this
camp and they essentially come knocking
on his door knocking on that door decide
what you thats his son he had to decide
what to do open up the door or keep the
door shop it's not a simple decision he
didn't know who's going to win the war
but see how he Sekot King we was open
the door ordered his servants blankets
food etc all 60 past the battle in his
how do we know this we know this the
story was even written by some of these
Jews immediately after the war if you go
to some of the fairly obscure histories
what happened during the war in Tunisia
was two or three miles about CLE saccade
who gave refuge to two Jews 60 Jews in
his farm in the Sun belly hit the snare
written back in 1945-46 Felisa scoreless
lost nobody never picked it up why
didn't keep it up or get to that demo
but the story is Doug welcome if you
actually
you know this man this is kind of the
way Helena who have is the son of one of
the most famous to me Ching literary
heroes ha bushnell behalf he served like
the nathaniel hawthorne information very
prominent in late 19th for the 14th
centuries this guy was was a his son was
a bit of a bohemian came to america in
1920s I saw from some remarkable photos
of him as as a photography blog here in
New York he hung out with jazz scene art
and architecture not your typical you
know Tunisia in the night for 20 to 30
anyway latest way back to Tunisia and
time of the Vichy and the German
occupation was in his hometown of mafia
the Tunisian coast and
to make a long story short he learned
that German officers address certain
German officer was had his sights on a
circle Jewish woman that woman there and
because he was the leader of the town
they had a special relationship of
Germans and in order to ensure that
these it was as little problem
vibration possible he's generally quiet
dying with them and he learned that one
Germans officer had his sights on this
Jewish woman it was a family business
relationship between this family algoma
have and he decided one night that is
very important to protect them so he
went to where they sounded tithing
family had already been kicked out of
their home that are already found refuge
and olive crest factory with the
extended family and Colin to home to his
farm on the outskirts of mafia and for
for several months protecting them on
the Islamic a fantastic story of
rescue and protection humanitarianism
and I am very pleased to say that holly
was thanks to the
thanks to the very important analysis
and decisions made by Mordecai LVL in
late two thousand and six in early two
thousand seven Colin on the web was the
first album to be forwarding nominee for
recognition by out machine as a
righteous eliminations
how it was his nomination was rejected
by the commission of the righteous and
then in the making of the documentary
film that
that I did again with the great
assistance in order high over the last
couple of years I found more
eyewitnesses more Jews or members of
that family we're willing to come
forward and offer their testing and
and now as a result of that the official
final in color do I have was reopened by
the commission of Mauritius last July
there's in utter silence from the
Commissioner ages and since last July on
but I remained hopeful and I
I stopped for me I have a lot of respect
to John version but
I appreciate judgment aboard I and
others who
this and I are being hopeful that
Howard's if not Khalid them than there
are other excited the process of doing
this film I discovered fantastic stories
I can't show a wonderful story of a man
named Joseph nakash for example who was
hounded by the Nazis in Tunis and found
refuge at the spanish two or three weeks
living in hama in a Turkish bath the
bath / gave him look stay here stay here
you can stay and I have this fantastic
testimony from cloud coverage in from
the Georgia Joseph nakash and then I
went to Tunis defy the amount and into
this i found the Sun habana who used
exactly the same words as Joseph Tkach
to describe it in person who's the owner
the guy
left hand urge Joseph to spend a couple
of weeks as long as something high in
his tongue out and it's a Verity stories
there are many other stories I'm sure
wait until but let me just close very
quickly how many rescuers were there in
aeroplanes we don't know but my my guess
is that the proportion is probably the
same probably the same in Europe if we
have so far six million Jews
exterminated in Europe 22,000 recognized
ranges perhaps a larger number only for
thousands of Jews from killed in our in
our plans somebody's that was their
proportion proportion is a head and I'm
sure we exceed I'm sure history exceeds
the hammer why haven't we heard these
stories before two very brief answers 1
we historians the best Jews trainees the
collective week we didn't look that hard
and second day they didn't want any hug
both are true we didn't look hard and
maybe what have you found
and I can tell you stories for example
about that remember a soldier see how
it's a cop it was written that it was
published in Tunisia what happy in his
farm in saqqaq family lore to ask his
children or grandchildren the story is
very different story is not that the
grandfather her father saved Jews their
story is that their grandfather her
father opened their farm an important
moment of the battle to take in German
prisoners of war it may or may not be
true I don't know if we do those things
of inches my sense is that somehow older
day between the 50s 60s and 70s it
became toxic and that society to talk
about protection insurance we in the
card they didn't want to be found
got it named up by me
you